[Music]
right yeah look incredibly every topic
did you pick this outfit oh no no no no
I just told me I just admired all me we
want to rule on our way here and I was
like I win okay everybody go home
well I my own called secondary ready all
right now Ryan has a chance to be the
first person from the Mickey Mouse crew
to win an Oscar but you could just write
does that intensify the competition been
successful let me play some about Ryan
he is so talented those gifted if he
does not win tonight it's the cards form
he's just just one of those guys I don't
know I think it's oh I met I think
there's some potential there and so let
me ask you mr. did you watch him on the
me table I'm sorry I watched you on the
novel
I mean I don't really remember but I'm
sorry that's right you know anything
about a week ago yeah I don't like
nobody that I don't remember anything
before 22 months ago yes and I want to
ask you about how no one can and you
don't understand how good it is I'm cool
you're sitting there with that child
you're like oh my god I love him yeah I
mean yeah most of the time and then
there's other moments where you're like
this is really hard and I don't know
what the hell I'm doing if you don't
have pain now you're ready for next
let's be honest is I believe it's one of
those things were like I love you but I
just don't know if I like you I started
to get annoying like you know when you
then want to change the diapers not
gonna good yes yes because know what the
diapers change I think he you know he's
almost through he's hitting his terrible
twos a little early so we're hoping to
get out of them a little
you